hi everyone
this is professor m.science and today i
want to discuss
functions of operators in another one of
our videos on rigorous quantum mechanics
operators are used to describe a wide
range of properties in quantum mechanics
for example hermitian operators are used
to describe physical observables like
the position
or the momentum of a particle and as
another example unitary operators are
used to describe physical processes
such as spatial translations or time
evolution but an important insight is
that we usually find
functions of operators when we work with
quantum mechanics for example
the translation operator can be written
as an exponential function of the
momentum operator
in this video we'll learn what we mean
by a function of an operator in some
ways they behave like the functions of
scalar variables that we're familiar
with
but in other ways they behave very
differently so we need to learn how to
properly work with them to avoid any
pitfalls
let's go an operator a acts on a state
psi to give a new state psi prime
in quantum mechanics we work with linear
operators
whose action on a linear superposition
of two states
is equal to the action on the first
state plus the action on the second
state
in this expression c1 and c2 are complex
scalars
another important point for today's
discussion is that the product of two
operators
a and b is defined by its action on a
ket
and this expression means that we first
act with b on psi
which gives a new state phi so that we
end up with a
phi and then the action of a on phi
gives another state chi now this is just
a quick reminder you can find all the
details about it in our video on
operators link in the description
linear operators are extremely important
in quantum mechanics
for example her hermitian operators
which are equal to their adjoint
are used to describe physical quantities
such as position momentum
or energy as another example unitary
operators
whose inverse is equal to the adjoint
are used to describe a range of
processes such as time or space
translations
again you can find a lot more detail on
all these concepts by following the
links to the corresponding videos in the
description
in quantum mechanics we very often
encounter functions of operators
for example the kinetic energy of a
particle of momentum p
is equal to this which includes the
square
of the momentum operator so the function
here is the power function
as another example the time evolution
operator in a conservative system
can be written as this exponential of
the operator h
which is the operator associated with
the total energy of the system and is
called the hamiltonian
this expression involves the exponential
function
the objective of this video is to
understand what we mean by expressions
like this
what are functions of operators and what
are their properties
the key building block of all our
discussion today is the power of an
operator
we can easily define the power n of an
operator
as the application of this operator n
times
so that there are n terms here
what we'll see in the rest of the video
is that we can build more complex
functions of operators such as the
exponential function
by simply using this expression for the
power of an operator
we're now ready to define the function
of an operator
consider a function f of some variable z
we also consider the power series
expansion of this function
where the fn are the expansion
coefficients
we next define the function f of an
operator a
as equal to the same power series
and we're using the same expansion
coefficients here
but now we have the powers of the
operator a here
and this is all we need to work with
functions of operators
now whenever we write a power series
there is always the question of
convergence of the series
this is actually something that we will
not consider further because most
functions that we need in quantum
mechanics are well behaved from this
point of view so convergence is a topic
we don't typically have to worry about
moving on as an example we can consider
the exponential function
the exponent of the variable z can be
written as this power series
and we can also write out the first few
terms explicitly
we then have that the exponential of an
operator a is given by the corresponding
power series with the same expansion
coefficients
and we can also write out the first few
terms explicitly
this is really all we need to work with
functions of operators
what we'll do in the rest of the video
is to explore some general properties of
this definition
we'll find that some things work as you
would expect for functions of scalar
variables
but some things work differently and it
is important to be aware of potential
pitfalls
let's first look at a potential pitfall
let's start with scalars
we can write that the product of two
exponentials
is equal to the exponential of the sum
about operators it turns out that this
formula is in general
not true for operators
to see this let's start with the left
hand side
using the power series definition we get
the expansion of the first exponential
times the expansion of the second
exponential
writing out the first few terms we get
this for the first exponential
and this for the second
multiplying through we get the power 0
term
the power 1 terms the power 2 terms
and so on by comparison let's consider
the right hand side
we again write down the power series
explicitly the first few terms are these
and we can simplify this expression to
get the power 0 term
the power 1 terms the power 2 terms
and so on comparing the two expressions
we see that the power zero terms here
and here are the same the power one
terms are also the same here
and here but the power two terms are not
the same
because in general two a b here is not
equal to
a b plus b a here these two terms are
only the same
if a and b commute but we know that for
operators a and b may not commute
this means that in general this relation
up here for operators
is an inequality
let's make some room the general
expression to combine exponentials is
actually known
and is called the baker campbell
hausdorff formula
the proof is not particularly
enlightening so i won't prove it here i
will simply state the result
if you're curious about the proof i'll
leave a link in the description for a
reference where you can find it
the general formula is that the
exponential of a times the exponential
of b
is equal to the exponential of c and c
is given by a long series whose first
few terms are these here
what we can see is that if a and b
commute then we can write an expression
equivalent
to that for scalars however if a and b
don't commute then this is no longer
true
now this is just an example but it is an
important one because it highlights that
when we work with functions of operators
we need to be very
careful many of the formulas that we're
familiar with when working with
functions of scalar variables do not
carry through to the case of
operators so we need to be aware of
potential pitfalls
next let's consider her mission
operators
if a is a hermitian operator can we say
anything
about a function of a to figure this out
let's consider the conjugate of
f of a writing the power series for the
function we get this
this is simply the adjoint of a sum so
it is equal to the sum of the adjoints
and in this step i've used the fact that
the adjoint of a scalar is its complex
conjugate here
here we have the adjoint of a power and
we know that the adjoint of a product
reverses the order of the terms
but as we only have the operator a in
the power we can simplify this
expression to this sum
finally if a is hermitian we can replace
a dagger with a
to get this so what do we have here
we can see that this expression almost
looks like the function
f of the operator a but not quite
because these expansion coefficients
appear as the complex conjugates
of the original ones this means that in
the most general case the function of a
hermitian operator
is not hermitian however very often
we're interested
in real functions f for example the
exponential function we were discussing
earlier
if a function f is real then its
expansion coefficients
f n are all real numbers in this case we
can now write the adjoint of the
function as equal to the latest
expression we got
but now using the fact that the fn are
real we have been able to remove the
complex conjugate from this term
and it is now equal to f of a
overall this means that if f is a real
function
and a is a hermitian operator then f of
a
is also a hermitian operator
next i want to consider the eigenvalue
equation
let this be the eigenvalue equation for
operator a
where as usual the lambda i are the
eigenvalues and the ui
are the eigenstates to explore what this
means for a function of a
let's consider f of a acting on an
eigenstate of
a we insert the power series definition
of f
a all acting on the eigenstate of a
each a acting on ui here is an instance
of the eigenvalue equation for a
so overall we extract the eigenvalue n
times
multiplying the eigenstate this means
that we can rewrite this power series in
terms of the eigenvalues
acting on the eigenstate this here is
simply the function
f of the eigenvalue so we end up with
this
so what does this mean if ui or the
eigenstate of an operator a
then looking here and here we see that
there are also the eigenstates of any
function of that operator
and if the lambda i are the eigenvalues
of an operator a
then the eigenvalues of a function of
the operator are simply the same
function of the eigenvalues of the
original operator
we're next going to look at a series of
relations involving commutators of
functions of operators
as functions of operators are defined
through the power series
then we first need to consider the
commutators between powers of operators
the first case is trivial the commutator
of an operator
a with a power of a writing it out we
get these two terms
we can collect the powers like this and
we get zero
this means that the commutator of an
operator a with any function of the
operator
is equal to zero for the second case
consider two different operators a and b
but we assume that they commute
the commutator of a with a power of b
can be spelled out like this and as a
and b commute we can rearrange this
expression to this
and overall we get 0. in turn this means
that the commutator of an operator a
with any function of another operator b
that commutes with a
is equal to zero for the third case
let's first make some room we now
consider the general situation when a
and b don't commute
unlike the two cases we've already
looked at in this case evaluating
commutators involving powers of
operators does not lead to nice
expressions
however there is a very important
special case and this is what we'll look
at
we're going to limit ourselves to the
situation when a
commutes with the commutator of a and b
and b also commutes with the commutator
of a and b
this means that even though a and b
don't commute they
each commute with their commutator now
at first side this special case may
appear somewhat random
but it turns out that it's a very
important case because it is true for
the position
and momentum operators x and p
don't commute but the commutator is
simply the scalar i h bar
this means that x commutes with the
commutator of x and p
and the same goes for p so whatever we
learn for this special case will
immediately apply to the position and
momentum operators
in this special setup the commutator of
a with the nth power of b
is equal to n times the commutator of a
with b
times b to the power of n minus 1.
what i want to do next is to prove this
relation
the proof is by induction any proof by
induction has two parts
the first part is that if we assume that
the relation is true for
n
then this implies that it is also true
for n plus one to see this let's write
the commutator of a with b
to the power n plus one and the first
step is to separate the second term like
this
from the video and commutator algebra we
know that we can write the commutator of
x with y z as equal to this term
plus this term
using this result we can rewrite our
expression into this first term
plus the second term
now feel free to stop here for a moment
to make sure that you're happy with this
step
moving on this here is simply the
expression for the value
n that we're assuming to be valid up
here
so we can therefore insert it to obtain
this for the first term
and we still have the same second term
for the next step we need to remember
that we're working in the special case
where b
commutes with the commutator of a and b
so this term
commutes with this term and we can
exchange their order to rewrite the
first term like this
and we still have the second term
finally we can take out a common factor
and we end up with
n plus 1 times the commutator times b
to the power n so this is the first part
of the proof by induction
we have confirmed the step up here
let's make some room the second part of
the proof is easier
all we need to show is that the relation
is true for the first few values of n
for n equals 0 for the left hand side
we have this commutator
it is equal to this commutator and every
operator commutes with the identity
for the right hand side as n is 0
we also get 0. this confirms that the
relation is true for n equals zero
for n equals one for the left-hand side
we simply have the commutator
and for the right-hand side we have this
which indeed gives the commutator so the
relation is also true for n equals 1.
now feel free to try a few more values
of n but you'll find that the relation
does indeed hold in all cases
overall we've first shown that if this
relation is true for n
then it's also true for n plus one and
we've also checked that the relation is
true for the first few values of
n putting this together we can conclude
that this relation up here
is therefore valid for any n completing
the proof by induction
let's recap what we have if a and b do
not commute
but a commutes with the commutator of a
and b
and b also commutes with the commutator
then the commutator of a with b to the
power n
is equal to this
we can now use this to calculate the
commutator of a with a function of b
the first step is to expand the function
in its power series
we then take the scalar expansion
coefficient outside the commutator to
get this
for this term here we can now use the
expression we derived up here and doing
so we end up with this expression
this commutator does not depend on n so
we can take it
out of the sum to get this expression
and this here is now a power series
which corresponds to the derivative
of f just to be absolutely clear i'm
using this prime here to indicate that
this is the derivative of f
with respect to its argument overall
this means that we can write this
commutator
as equal to this other commutator times
the derivative of the function of b
let's finish by looking at the concrete
example of this expression when the
operators a and b are the position
and momentum operators we already
explained that the position and momentum
operators obey the conditions under
which this expression applies
so all we have to do is to consider
their commutator
which is equal to ihbar this means that
we can write the commutator of
x with a function of p as
equal to i h bar times the derivative of
the function of p
similarly the reverse commutator is
equal to
minus i h bar so that the commutator of
p with a function of x is equal to minus
i h bar
times the derivative of the function of
x
these expressions are extremely useful
and you can find an example of their use
in our video on
erinfest's theorem that you can find
linked in the description
in our study of quantum mechanics we'll
find ourselves working with functions of
operators
all the time now that we've discussed
their mathematical properties you're
ready to see them in action for example
you can check our videos on the time
evolution operator
or on the translation operator both of
which are given by exponential functions
of other operators and as always if you
like the video
please subscribe